they've gone from positivity rate of
about four or five percent to now
in excess of 15 and that's one of the
issues we have throughout the rio de
anda valley
it has been increasing too i we cannot
attribute it to the immigrants we cannot
but we are concerned and we're trying to
do whatever we can
to keep our residents safe javier
villalobos the mayor of mcallen texas
the border city where more than 7
thousand migrants
with covet have been released by border
patrol since february this as
the bite administration begins flying
central american and mexican families
deep
into mexico to deter repeat crossings as
a time
of rising coveted concerns to dig deeper
into this spokesman for the national
border patrol council
and local 3307 in the rio grande valley
chris
cabrera chris thanks for taking time i
know you're tired
you guys are working long hours but now
this
coveted threat mayor via lobos saying
that the threat to
you right there in the rgv in excess of
16
positivity rate how bad is it
you know it's pretty bad i know we have
um at least 80 of our agents
well more than 80 of our agents have
tested positive we have at least
150 in quarantine um and it's
the numbers are growing every day it's
it's getting
out of control here and it's unfortunate
that the administration is just turning
a blind eye
to what's going on down here and putting
our communities uh
at risk chris you're not only an agent
in the rgv but you're also
a resident of the community of mcallen
how concerning
is it now that you've got a mayor
pleading for help
in a federal government tying your hands
so to speak
you know it's very concerning and and
we're thankful that
mayor via lobos is doing what he's doing
it's unfortunate the the last mayor of
mcallen just kind of turned a blind eye
to it as well as
the county administration they were
constantly saying there was there was no
crisis down here there was no state of
emergency
and only when the the news broke the
story of
of covet positive uh people that were
released from custody
are roaming around the towns and and
potentially infecting
our citizens um you know that that's
when people started to wake up
chris what could the federal government
what could the administration do
right now to help alleviate this crisis
well you know i think they need to come
down here and take a look
you know even you've seen some of our
makeshift intake area is right right
here in the mcallen area and la jolla
area
it's just a makeshift ball field where
where we have 400 500 people there at a
time
waiting outside for for a bus to come
and there's very little protection for
the elements there's no restroom
facilities
people are just using the restroom in
full view of the public on the side of
the road
and that's disgusting not to mention uh
very dangerous
as far as some of the illnesses that can
come from that and you know they have
money for for for the arts they have
money for people to
stay home and not work but we can't even
get a portage on down here so
it's time they they really took this
serious come down and solve this because
real people are are paying the price
down here we're having
heat casualties every day from sitting
out in the in the hot sun and
and the humid weather we have down here
chris the
crisis isn't just in the rgv where you
are
2 000 miles away fox news just
getting this video in from early this
morning
at the ocean beach pier in near san
diego california you see
a panga washed up peter pelham that shot
this video
one of my closest surfing friends he
went out to go for a surf there
and the border patrol was there they
looked back on the surfline
camera and saw it about 2 45 a.m local
california time
12 individuals jumped out of this panga
scattered left the boat
behind those are got aways how much of a
threat
is the open border right now in terms of
national security
in the in the no the the unknown folks
that are crossing
uh without getting uh apprehended
you know the the numbers for godaways
are are are astronomical i know the
the administration the patrol puts out a
certain amount that they're
you know at the you know 40 20 but we're
closer to
maybe a 50 percent got away rate here in
the nationwide
the vast majority of people that are
trying to get away do get away because
we just don't have the manpower
to cover we have very few people out in
the field because we're all babysitting
or sick
well and just as a testament to the toll
the human toll this crisis is taking we
have video
this week you were assisting a toddler a
tender age
migrant out in the field we can see
there this young girl how
bad is it how much of a human toll is it
taking
you know we luckily the border patrol
has our we have our own emts to respond
until
ems could get there but our medics are
running back and forth every day
all day whenever we're on duty uh three
four five seven ten calls to shift
that little girl she was uh unconscious
when we found her when when they brought
her up and
the agent on the scene did a good job of
cooling her down but we're seeing that
daily and
and it's heartbreaking to see anybody in
that condition but even so
more so a three-year-old it is indeed
chris cabrera
with the national border patrol council
in the rgv chris thank you
stay safe